You've seen all the headlines and if
these predictions are even half right
then artificial intelligence may soon
outright most of us. So in this video,
I'm going to give you the non-fiction
writer survival plan. A way to keep your
writing valuable, relevant, and
impossible to replace. And I'll walk you
through the five writers skills, the
ones where we still beat the machines
that will matter most to your readers in
the age of AI. Now, what I'm going to
share here is not a list of style tips.
You know, like avoid the M-dash or don't
use these sentence structures or avoid
the word delve. No, instead it's five
ways of approaching your writing, of
understanding the three-way relationship
between you, your reader, and the text
that's going to set you apart. And along
the way, I'll give you some simple
practical techniques for building these
muscles so that you know not only what
skills will keep you relevant, but how
to start practicing them right now. All
right, so we all know that voice of AI,
but one thing I've been thinking about
recently is what is a writer's voice
exactly? Now, some people call it
writing style and some call it the
unique fingerprint, but whatever you
call it, it's one of these complex
phenomena that resists easy analysis.
And a great way to think about this is
with science. So in science, the default
move is reductionism. So if there's
anything in the world that you want to
understand, what you do is you break it
down into its fundamental constituents.
So for example, if you want to
understand matter, well then you break
matter down into atoms until you get to
the level where you can't divide
something anymore. But what we've
discovered in recent decades is that
there are certain phenomena in the world
which resist this reduction. These are
called complex adaptive systems and your
writing voice is one of them. So for an
example of a complex adaptive system,
think of an ant colony. All right, so
you have this intricate, perfectly
organized structure, and yet there is no
single ant, like a construction foreman,
kind of directing everybody on how to
control it. There's no central
controller, and there's no map. That
whole structure and its weird little
patterns, which suit the purposes of the
ant colony perfectly, emerges from the
bottom up. From thousands of very simple
creatures following very simple rules.
And the stock market works the same way.
So, if you break the stock market down
into its constituent elements, what you
get are consumers. And just like ants,
consumers follow a very simple script.
They buy low, and they sell high. But,
from that very simple behavior, a
complex macro-level pattern emerges that
no one could predict by studying the
parts in isolation. And I think these
complex adaptive systems are a really
good way of thinking about what your
writing voice is. Like, yes, if we want
to try to understand the writing voice
or the writing style of this writer,
that writer, or you, then yeah, we could
break it down into its constituent
elements, you know, the the grammar and
the word choice. But, you can't describe
a writer's voice just by cataloging
those elements. Voice is an emergent
phenomena, just like the patterns that
we see in the stock market or in ant
colonies. It arises from the interaction
of those elements with something that's
a lot harder to pin down, which is the
writer's lived experience. Now, I know
that lived experience sounds like a
pretty woo-woo term, and I almost didn't
use it because it's the kind of phrase
that people cite as evidence when what
they mean is a bunch of subjective
feelings. And I didn't want to resort
this section about your writing voice to
vibes, essentially. But when it comes to
your writing voice, that's exactly what
it is. It's vibes. It's something that's
not quite scientific. And those vibes
are what are uniquely human. AI can do a
lot of things, but one thing it cannot
do is have its own lived experience and
get its own vibes. Because models don't
live. They can't feel. They can't smell,
taste, or be embarrassed in the middle
of high school gym class and carry that
around for the rest of my life and have
difficulty interacting with people and
develop social anxiety and the only way
I can communicate with people is through
these parasocial relationships in my
writing and my YouTube videos. You know
what I mean, right? Those feelings,
those specific complexes that we all
carry around, are yours alone. And that
is your asset. So your writing voice is
not your sentences, it's not your
grammar, it's not your word choice, it's
the particular blend of experience,
expertise, and perspective that makes
your bona fides, your diction, your word
choice, and the way you express yourself
irreducibly yours. But AI is the exact
opposite of that. It is the sum total of
every voice on the internet. And when
you take thousands of singular voices
and you blend them into something
smooth, homogeneous, and hygienic, what
you get is slop. So you see a lot of
people these days uploading custom
instructions to their language models,
telling the AI to not use certain
phrases, as if tricking the reader is
the goal. But like, why would you want
to trick your readers? What is your
writing for? What are you doing here? If
you're watching this video, it's because
you're trying to find some meaning in
all of this, some purpose. Like, why are
we writing? Why are we trying to learn
how to write? What's the game here? And
if that's the case, then you don't need
AI to do it for you because you're not
just producing content. The game is not
trick my readers into thinking this AI
was written by me. What you're doing is
sharing something of yourself. You're
extending your thinking and you're
trying to connect with real readers.
That connection is something that only
you can offer. Now, for the second
point, here's something interesting
about LLMs that I haven't seen anyone
talk about, which is that they seem
almost terrified of biology. What I've
noticed is that the metaphors that AI
produces often feel uncanny. Right? So,
they're formally correct. They share all
the right formal rhetorical features of
a metaphor, but the two images that they
link together always seem just strange,
like a few degrees off. And I think
that's because AI is disembodied. So, it
doesn't have a body, so it doesn't have
the same frame of reference that we do.
Like, what's an example of a good
metaphor? Okay, a few that jump to mind.
One I read in uh my undergrad. It was a
Middle Eastern Studies class. I for- It
might have been Mahfouz. I forget who
wrote this, but he was describing the
relationship between a mother and a
daughter and he said that they were as
close as an orange to its navel. That's
a simile, not a metaphor. But isn't that
beautiful? The mother and daughter were
as close as an orange to its navel.
That's a perfect metaphor. The second
one comes from garbage collectors in New
York City who apparently have a
beautiful metaphor for the maggots that
they find in the trash, disco rice. That
is about as perfect a metaphor as you
can ever ask for. But disco rice and the
orange and its navel are two metaphors
that you will never get from AI. Those
metaphors are visceral because they come
from people who have lived experience.
Now, the explanation for why you need
this kind of embodied experience to come
up with metaphors that work is explained
by this book Metaphors We Live By. All
right, so in this book it's it's by
these two linguists and they show that
metaphors are not just these poetic
flourishes that we add on top of ideas
for style. In fact, a metaphor is really
how our brains make sense of the world.
So, you can find metaphors all over the
place if you just look at everyday
expressions such as you attacked every
point in my argument. Like that's a
metaphor. You attacked my argument, but
that metaphor tells us something about
the way that we think, the way that we
conceive of argument in our mind. The
same is true of time is running out.
When you think about that phrase,
there's a metaphor baked into it, which
is the idea of time moving forward on a
line. So, when you think about metaphors
this way, you can start to see the
hidden conceptual frameworks that
organize our thought. These phrases are
like windows into how we experience the
world in our bodies and I think that's
why the metaphors which come from AI
always sound a little alien, like
they're they're they're not from here.
And the poet Ocean Vuong describes this
really well. He says that a metaphor is
a kind of portal. It takes you from
somewhere unfamiliar and links you to
somewhere familiar, but the key here is
that the familiar thing has to modify or
amplify our understanding of the
unfamiliar thing. That's what makes a
metaphor work, and that's what make AI
metaphors fail. So, they share the same
rhetorical structure as a real metaphor.
They link an unfamiliar thing to a
familiar concept, but the connection
seldom lands. It's a lot like that Steve
Buscemi meme, "How you doing, fellow
humans?" Close, but no cigar. Because
the entity that's generating the
metaphor has never actually ex-
perienced anything. Again, it's a
pattern recognition machine, not a flesh
and blood being. Now, you, on the other
hand, are the genuine article, and you
have that in common with your readers.
So, the metaphors that occur to you
spontaneously are speaking the same
language as your readers, which is a
language that is grounded in physical
reality, in the body, in lived
experience, in a way that AI never will.
Now, for the third point, here's a line
that you will not get from AI, and
spoiler warning, this is the final line
from Cormac McCarthy's novel Suttree.
So, if you haven't read it, then skip
ahead 15 seconds. "Somewhere in the gray
wood by the river is the huntsman, and
in the brooming corn and in the
castellated press of cities. His work
lies all wares and his hounds tire not.
I have seen them in a dream, slaverous
and wild, and their eyes crazed with
ravening for souls in this world. Fly
them. Fly them. Isn't that strange?
Like, where does that verb even come
from? We don't fly hounds. We fly
airplanes, we fly helicopters. Now, we
flee from people and hounds, but that's
not the word that McCarthy chose. He
chose fly. And that is a strange,
rule-breaking choice that is exactly
what gives this sentence its power.
Like, that strangeness forces you to
take a double take and it kind of hangs
in your ear as you finish the book. I
read this book about 6 years ago and
I've never forgotten that line and the
kind of shiver that it gave me. Now, if
you give that line to your AI assistant
writer, then it's going to flag out the
grammatical error and smooth it right
over. And that's a problem because great
writers don't just follow rules. They
break them with specific effects in
mind. And again, that's something that
AI will never do. Now, yes, you have to
learn the rules first and writers don't
like it when I say this. They think I'm
coming in like a finger-wagging English
professor, but look, a chef needs to
know the techniques before they can
start inventing. A musician needs to
know the scales before they can start
bending them. But it's only upon
learning the rules that you can start
breaking them deliberately,
purposefully, and with a kind of skill
and to achieve certain effects. But to
see how you can bend these rules, think
about Shakespeare's sonnets. All right,
so the sonnet is a very rigid form. It's
got a fixed rhyme scheme, fixed meter,
fixed length, and Shakespeare follows
all these rules. But if you read his
sonnets, then throughout the sequence,
what you're going to see is that he's
also wrestling with the form, right?
He's pushing against its constraints and
trying at times to break out of its
structure in order to capture something
the form can't quite contain. And that
wrestling with form and its strictures
is a very human kind of energy that gets
carried through the language. Now, AI,
by contrast, is teacher's pet. All
right, it's a goody-two-shoes. It
follows the rules always because it's a
pattern recognition machine. It's a
parrot. And you will never get that kind
of sublimated energy from it, the sense
of a consciousness that is straining
against this confinement, the constraint
of form. Now, look, maybe you can
program your AI to break the rules, but
of course, at the end of the day, the
point here is that only you can break
the rules in a way that actually
matters. And for the fourth point, I
think the deepest reason that AI writing
disappoints us so much is that it has no
stakes. All right, so to tell you a
little bit about stakes and why they
matter, let me tell you a little story
about the hardest class that I ever
took, which was a critical theory
seminar in my second year of university,
my undergraduate degree. So, the
professor must have seen something in me
because at the start of the semester,
even though I was only in my second
year, I think I went up to talk to him
at the end of the class. It was an
American lit class, and he invited me up
to join a senior-level theory seminar.
So, it was me and some other people who
were older than me and much more
advanced in the program, which meant
that I was completely out of my depth,
and I was sitting next to students who
went on to secure hundreds of thousands
of dollars in grants and scholarships,
and
I was I was really green in this world.
And the format of the class was really
interesting. It was that like It was a
small seminar, so there were five or six
of us, and we had a reading list, and
every class, of course, we were all
required to do the reading, which was
pretty It was kind of like a branch of
philosophy. Uh we were reading Derrida
and Lacan and Lyotard, and I really had
no contacts for any of the arguments
that were taking place here. But the
requirement was that, of course, we all
had to read it, but one student in the
seminar for each reading would also be
required to write a two-page paper,
called a precis, which both summarizes
the argument of the reading that we all
did last night, and then advances an
argument against it. So, kind of
responding to the text. And the class,
you know, we didn't have the teacher at
the front of the classroom giving us a
lecture, instead it was kind of
student-led, and he would jump in to
help us articulate our points or provide
some extra context, but it was all us.
So, that class had stakes. All right?
Not only did I need to go home and
understand the stuff. And by the way,
this is long before AI. This might have
actually been before Wikipedia. I have
to think about that. Like, we we didn't
have any outside source of people
summarizing these arguments that we
could draw on. We had to deal with the
original source material, and then
explain it in our own words, and then
argue against it. And there were some
nights where I was up until 2:00, 3:00,
4:00 in the morning working on these
papers. And now that I look back, like
I'm an English professor now, and I know
that a lot of my students are just kind
of, you know, fudging their way through
these papers with AI. And one of the
things I think about when I reflect on
that class is like, what is lost? Like,
is it Is it a Is it always a good thing?
Right? That this work is now made
easier. What's lost in that? Right? What
And what did I gain through struggling
through it? Why did I work that hard?
Why did it matter so much to me? Would
it have been better for me to have a
Wikipedia where I could find summaries
of the arguments or an AI to explain it
for me, or even I would have never dared
use AI in this kind of classroom, but I
imagine some people probably might risk
it, which is to have AI summar- write
your paper for you. But what Why was
this so important to me? Why did I work
that hard? Well, I think the reason that
I worked so hard, the reason that I got
so much from that class, and what I
worry that many writers are losing these
days by relying on AI is stakes. People
I respected and by whom I wanted to be
respected were going to read my paper.
So, my reputation is on the line and
that's when real writing happens.
Incidentally, this is also the
motivation behind Jeff Bezos' famous
five-page memo. So, you might already
know that Jeff Bezos at Amazon banned
PowerPoint. So, if there's going to be a
meeting, then someone has to write a
five-page memo, which is a document that
outlines the issue, traces the writer's
thinking, and grounds their proposed
solutions in the facts on the page. And
so, at the start of the meeting, no one
speaks, everyone reads. And your boss is
in the room, your colleagues are in the
room, and every word that you wrote is
being read and evaluated. Now, that kind
of accountability produces clarity. It
produces depth, and it produces real
writing. AI has none of that. There are
no consequences for being mediocre. And
when it makes a mistake and you point it
out, it just says, "You're absolutely
right." And then it corrects itself. No
embarrassment, no growth. It's like an
incompetent intern, some kid with a
summer job. It's not a social being. It
doesn't care what you think of it. And
this actually reminds me that David
Foster Wallace, the novelist, had a rule
in his creative writing class, which is
that nothing can be submitted unless it
had been revised at least two or three
times before. And I remember reading an
account of a student who was in his
class who got a tongue lashing because,
you know, they had only edited their
work once or something like that. So, he
understood that real stakes are what
produce real writing. And so, when these
stakes disappear, I think that's when
writing becomes a chore, and that's when
people turn to AI. So, what I think is
really important is to reacquaint
yourself with writing that has stakes.
Put something online with your name on
it that you would not be embarrassed for
others to read.
In my own writing, I find that is a
great motivation to really nail my
ideas. When you really start putting
your name on something, you do become
conscious of the impression that it
leaves on your reader. And I think
that's what drives great work. And for
the last point, I think in many ways
that AI writing peaked with ChatGPT-2.
And so that early model went off the
rails. And you could give it the first
lines to a story and then ask it to
continue the story, kind of like a
exquisite corpse or whatever. So you
could give it a line like, "In the
shower, he was" and then give it to AI
to finish it. And you would get
something insane like, "He was eating a
lemon and thinking about his ex-wife in
a gurney." You know, completely
unexpected, genuinely surprising, and
something you could not just copy and
paste into a newsletter. But it could
actually send your imagination somewhere
you never would have gone on your own.
And that's a great use of AI as a
co-pilot, right? Not something that you
can outsource your writing to, but
something you can kind of bounce ideas
off of and kind of something surprising.
And that might spur some divergent
thinking of your own. Like, that's fun.
But that is an old model. And all of
that fun has been programmed out of it
now. The unpredictability has been
smoothed away and paved over. And what
we have left is a parrot that produces
the most probable, most
middle-of-the-road answer every time.
All right, so this quality that human
writers have that AI is losing after we
got each new model, it's losing it more
and more. We can call whimsy or creative
unpredictability. And it's not so much a
quality as an approach to writing.
Right? This is This is a way of
approaching your writing as though
you're just following a thread into the
unknown, pulling on a thread to the
sweater just to see where it goes. I
once read this interview with a
psychoanalyst named Martha Nussbaum who
was talking about her writing process.
And she noted that she had this special
relationship with her typewriter. So, in
psychoanalysis, there is this concept
called a transitional object. So,
something like your favorite stuffed
animal or the security blanket. It's
It's a thing that you kind of attach to
as an infant and imbue with these
qualities of safety and protection. And
when you're with them, you feel
unguarded and you can kind of lose
yourself in it. So, it gives you a
feeling of safety, but also a feeling of
like security, right? And so, in And
it's in that secure environment that
play can take place. Right? When you no
longer feel secure, you can't lose
yourself in the fun and imagination of
play. So, Nussbaum was saying that I
think her father might have been a
writer or something. For whatever
reason, she
attached to his typewriter as one of
these transitional objects. And so, for
her, the typewriter was not an
instrument of anxiety like it is for you
and I, but a toy, which is a thing to
play with. And I always try to remember
that frame. Now, I'm not like Nussbaum.
I cannot say that I just lose myself in
my writing, unfortunately, but I try to.
Right? And so, if you think of writing
as this anxiety-inducing medium of
judgment
through which you put your ideas out
there and then people evaluate them and
evaluate you, then of course you're
going to approach this craft with
anxiety. But, if you think of it as a
place, like an environment, try to think
of your your writing as a space that you
enter, which is a space of play, an
extension of your thinking, one where
there's not a definite end. It's not I
need to sit down and and finish this
work. It's that let's see where this
goes. I wonder where, you know, play.
Remember that? If you can just think of
your writing as an extension of your
thinking, as a tool for pulling on the
ribbon of your own curiosity, then you
stop performing and you can start
discovering. So, that's the space and I
really do think it's important to
consider your writing as a space, a kind
of chamber in your mind where you can
discover new things and you can be
excited and you can experiment with new
things and and deal with an
unpredictable world. You follow the
thread of your own curiosity, not
because it leads somewhere that you've
pre-decided, right? You're not following
the You're not following instructions,
you're not cut You're You're not taking
a pre-planned route somewhere. You're
just following your interest and you let
the writing surprise you. Needless to
say, AI cannot do this. It has been
optimized to produce the expected, the
safe, and the average. But, real
creativity is a distinctly human trait.
I have a whole argument about this. If
you want to learn more about it, read
David Deutsch. I won't get into it here,
but it comes from the same place as all
the other things on this list of things
that make us distinctly human. Being
alive, having a body, and having
something at stake. That's your
advantage, that's your moat. Use it.
Because writing without AI is not about
tying one hand behind your back. It's a
fundamentally different approach to
writing altogether. And if you want to
see what that looks like in practice,
then you need to watch this video next
because it's going to show you how to
use writing in two ways, as a tool for
thinking and as a tool for
communication. So, be sure to go check
it out.